hello I'm here with David Bremen the
creator of the ambitious and exciting
elite dangerous which is finally coming
to Xbox one it's exciting yeah too
likely to be here at e3 showing it how
was the show bin so far with the with
elite dangerous specifically oh it's
been great I mean the reception has been
wonderful it was great obviously first
with the microsoft conference and
obviously the daily show we're on but
also people playing it now and it's live
in the world who already got people
playing the game and having a lot of fun
so when did the discussions begin with
Microsoft because there's obviously a
special relationship going on there with
the preview program well absolutely I
mean we've worked with Microsoft for a
very long time we're doing we done
launch title on Xbox one of course with
zoo tycoon and then scream ride so our
tools and technology are also very well
tested but we obviously keep talking to
them and know the possibility of doing
elite dangerous came up yeah of course I
mean it's a very interesting game and
people have been really loving it on PC
for those players who have a lot of
experience with the game thus far what
are the difference is going to be that
they might encounter for the xbox one
version well that the first thing
obviously is you're playing in your
sitting room we we have a truly
excellent audio team at frontier and it
always upsets me seeing a lot of PC
players tend to play with stereo
speakers often speakers sort of its high
on the debt whereas the 5.1 or 7.1 audio
sounds so good that I think a lot more
players on xbox will be playing on a
really good audio setup you're also
playing sitting back in your seat which
is not sort of nice and relaxed way of
doing it I think that's the biggest
difference the game itself is is the
same however we are bringing soon to
Xbox what we showed in the daily show
and have talked about which is this
close quarters combat which is a new
mode in the games outside the game it
allows you to practice after you've done
the training missions I would suggest
doing player on player combat it's a
championship type setup where you play
either teams or individually against
each other in arenas and it's it's great
fun I think one of the more interesting
features of the pc version anyway when
it comes to hardware and you know
technology that opens up new ways to
interface with the game are some of the
the head and eye tracking stuff that
goes on what is there any chance that
that connect will enable you to do some
interesting things like that on the Xbox
one it's not something we've been
looking at at the moment it's something
we may look at in the future but it's
not planned okay when you look at
something like hololens I'm sure your
imagination must run wild yes if your
wildest dreams what would you like to do
with the hololens you know potentially
fairly dangerous well I think the the
challenge early dangerous is you're in
another world it works very very well
for VR because you're seated so it
nicely matches if you're sitting on a
couch in the sitting room it works very
well I think the issue with holidays is
the AR you know that I think we're more
set up for VR experience having said
that you Hollins is very interesting I
just always imagine having the sort of
you know the tool set and the you know
just the cockpits right in front of me
just projected but that's my own
personal wishes cuz you get that in you
get that one beyond you certainly you
certainly do yeah so let's talk about
what he's doing at the moment so right
now he's loading up a combat training
scenario can you walk me through I guess
you know what what it's like to sort of
training get used to this for people who
have not played the game before um well
you obviously these are training
scenarios which are the same each time
and they're they're great from a player
point of view because you can get used
to the controls in environment where
you're not at risk you not look silly in
front of other players or whatever and
they're they're graded in a in terms of
difficulty so you can do them sort of in
order if you like or you can skip
forward to one that's sort of a bit
harder
and you also can try out some of the
ships that it will take you a while to
get to in game and see what they feel
like see how exciting the are to play
but in terms of the gameplay and also
you can play these now on the game
preview program for free because you can
play for a few hours before you decide
whether you like the game or not and we
went running live on xbox now as we
speak but it's really a gentle it is
intended to be an intro to the game
we've also got lots of videos that
explain the controls it's funny it's
like when we first started playing
first-person shooters a decade or more
ago on console and I saw a lot of
players just sort of looking at their
feet because you hadn't got used to the
camera look separate from the moving
around and I think there's a learning
experience here so it won't click
straight away but when it does click
it's really great it feels really
wonderful to be in control of a
spaceship and it feels very natural and
then there are a lot of other things you
can start doing some that are a lot more
sort of sister Katie we have something
called flight assist which helps your
ship it flies quite like an airplane so
it's quite intuitive you can turn that
off and you can do things like swiveling
on the spot doing some really amazing
maneuvers there are loads of videos on
YouTube of people doing these in in the
game a great guy called this an owner so
some wonderful videos like that um but
that's the sort of thing you can learn
and the point of this is you know it's
not so much its role playing it's
actually you are learning those skills
and you get better and better at it and
then CQC is intended so you can really
hone those skills and you just go
straight into the game which is great
and then you can use those skills in the
game ultimately to help you in combat
things because you know you can play the
game whether it's this bounty hunter a
pirate an assassin you know in lots of
different ways where combat is key and
he's great fun yeah I mean there's you
know obviously been a revival of the the
space sim / combat you know genres and
I'm personally very excited but I'm
curious to hear why you think that you
know these games are so special and and
how they manage to just capture our
wonder like they have been doing for
decades
yeah I think it's a shame that we
haven't seen any real space sims for
quite a long time now we've had a round
a decade of nothing and I think it's
because we've got a lot of sort of
follow my leader a moment where a game
is successful and they see a lot of
games that are quite like it ironically
we're seeing lots and lots of space into
the moment which by the way I think is a
great thing i love this i love these
games it's just i would rather have had
them spaced over time so mortifying five
years ago it said how many how many
unrealized ideas do you have left to put
into elite dangerous matters that's
absolutely nice we've talked about some
of them and you know they will come over
time but it's it's already a very very
rich game there is a lot there and a lot
of things to do absolutely do you view
it as a as a platform of sorts where
it's something you is going to be adding
to this for years to come that's exactly
the intention we've indicated what some
of those things are and we've done a
whole sequence of updates the third
major update power-play came out a few
weeks ago and being really well received
and also by the way is on xbox you know
so all of that content is on the xbox
what if you want to play it it's it's
for the top sort of political level four
players we've had players who played
thousands of hours now you know it is
astonishing the dedication people are
showing to these games but also for
those players to show that they can sort
of interact with other players and do
things like bringing and government see
changing the geographic you know the
politics of the galaxy yeah which i
think is very it's very interesting that
you can do that yeah it definitely
creates this this long tail for a game
that is something that's pretty new for
for the industry at large I mean you
know discounting MMOs like World of
Warcraft which been around for a very
long time now when you were making games
you know years ago it was there was a
lot of iterations on hardware there was
new stuff to open a chase how does it
feel for you as a creator to just sort
of have a solid foundation that you can
work with and just be creative without
worrying about you know chasing the next
best thing when it comes to hardware
well I mean in the sort of 32 years I've
been in the business actually there's
been a regular rate of change all the
way through and I think now is not
really any different the key thing
though is and why this is the best time
it's ever being we have a real sort of
Golden Age if you like
is that we can do is this move we're now
going directly to players one of the big
changes I think for me is the previously
what determined whether a game would get
made was the route to market and the
publishers you know through the high
street now it's actually the quality and
what people want you know so this this
engagement that you see now with the
loot dangerous which which is wonderful
is the two-way street but it also means
that the games are just going to get a
lot better and we'll see more and more
games filling essentially the gaps
between other games we got the
concentrations of games in game space if
you like with huge gaps between them I'd
love to see more new games and we are
starting to see them with the excellent
indecent as gaming ever been better than
it is right now I don't think so people
say that the 80s were very good and they
were great fun but I think time is
amazing it condenses things there was a
lot of rubbish in the 80s huge amount of
rubbish and only the good ones that
survived which is a good thing and same
with music you know that but and I think
now actually there are fewer rubbish
games that I've seen now than I've ever
seen and actually I with us with a lot
of them even the ones that are less fun
to play you think actually I love that
idea or that's really beautiful in it
well you certainly made something very
impressive and I'm sure xbox one owners
are probably already enjoying it at home
i'm here at the show I don't have the
chance to do that but rest assured once
I'm back after the show yeah after the
show everyone thanks for joining me
David thank you for joining me on the
the show stay tuned to gamespot com for
more coverage of elite dangerous and the
rest of the games at e3 2015 thank you
you